so you have some now i don't know the
full history of this
but i think it's kind of uh interesting
you have
some tension with mr richard stallman
um over the i mean he kind of represents
this kind of like
like you mentioned free software
uh
sort of a dogmatic focus on
yeah all all information must be free
must be free so what is there an
interesting way to uh paint a picture of
the disagreement you have with richard
through the years
my my basic opposition is
that you know when you say information
must be free
uh to a really extreme form
that turns into you know
all people whose job is the
production of
everything from movies to software
they must all take a vow of poverty
because information must be free
and that doesn't work for me right and
and i
and i don't i don't want to be wildly
rich
i am not wildly rich um
i do okay um
but i do actually you know you know i've
you know i can feed my children yeah i
totally agree with you i
it does just make me sad that sometimes
the closing of the source
for some reason the people that
like a bureaucracy begins to build and
sometimes
it doesn't it hurts the product oh
absolutely
absolutely it's always sad and there's
and there is
a there is a balance in there that's a
balance
um and you know it's
it's not hard hard over you know
rapacious capitalism and
and it's and it's not hard over in the
other direction
um and you know a lot of
the the open source movement they
they they have been managing to find a
path to
um actually making money right so
doing things like service and support
works for
a lot of people um
you know and there are some some ways
where
it's it's kind of um
some of them are are a little a little
perverse right so
as you know a part of things like this
sarbanes-oxley act and
various people's interpretations of all
kinds of accounting principles
um and this is kind of a worldwide thing
but if you've got a
a corporation that is depending on some
piece of software
um you know the often
you know various accounting and
reporting standards say if you don't
have a support contract
on this thing that that your business is
depending on
then that's bad
you know so so so you know if you've got
a if you've got a database you
need to pay for support and and so
but there's a difference between
you know the the sort of support
contracts that
you know the average open source
database
uh producer charges
and what somebody who is truly rapacious
like oracle charges it's a it's a it's a
balance
it's it is it is absolutely a balance
and you know there are there are
a lot of a lot of different ways
to make you know the math
work out for everybody um
and you know the
the very you know
uh un unbalanced sort of
you know like like the winner takes all
thing that that happens in so much of
of modern commerce um
that just doesn't work for me either
you